In today’s pop culture, avoiding spoilers
is everything while awaiting a highly-anticipated
movie.
But sometimes, studios can’t contain themselves.
We’re not talking about trailers or advertising.
There are instances where the film will spoil
itself.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Spoilers Hidden
At The Start Of Popular Films.
21 Jump Street
21 Jump Street is full of twists, and a humorous
one comes at the end when Johnny Depp reprises
his role from the TV show.
All through the film, he was unrecognizable
as an undercover drug dealer, but he gave
up his secret in the film’s first act.
When Schmidt and Jenko investigate his gang
in a park, a bearded man insults the two policemen,
saying that if they’re cops, he’s a DEA
agent.
Turns out, that’s precisely what he is when
he makes his reveal at the end.
If only the dealers had been paying attention,
they may have been able to avoid a whole lot
of trouble.
Shaun of the Dead
Edgar Wright has confessed that Ed essentially
sums up the plot of the film when he tries
to cheer Shaun up with a binge drink game
plan before they encounter a zombie outbreak.
First, the two will have a Bloody Mary, then
grab a bite at the King’s Head, followed
by a Couple, a Little Princess, and then stagger
back to the bar for shots.
They do all of that, just not in the way they
envisioned.
It doesn’t seem like much when you’re
first watching it, but it’s a clever bit
of foreshadowing that spells everything out
to an unsuspecting audience.
No Country for Old Men
Anton Chigurh is one of cinema’s most intimidating
villains, and he’s essentially a human Terminator.
Llewelyn Moss thinks he has what it takes
to bring Chigurh down, but he was doomed before
the two even crossed paths.
In the beginning of the film, Llewelyn is
hunting elk, and manages to hit one with a
bullet.
But it doesn’t kill the animal, just wounds
it.
It’s a tease of what’s to come, as Llewelyn
cannot find a way to stop Chigurh from coming
after him, no matter what he does.
Llewelyn does injure his pursuer, but Anton
is an unkillable machine.
Shutter Island
The big twist in Shutter Island is that Federal
Marshall Teddy Daniels is in face a patient
at the Ashcliffe facility, and his partner
“Chuck” is his head psychiatrist operating
a role playing exercise.
It catches moviegoers off-guard, but attentive
viewers were clued in before all the action
takes place.
When Teddy and Chuck arrive on the island,
they’re asked to hand over their weapons.
Chuck struggles with the holster of his gun,
signifying that he’s not experienced with
firearms, and not a U.S. Marshall.
Teddy can’t believe what he’s seeing,
but it all makes sense in the end.
Total Recall
When the citizens of Total Recall are looking
to mix up their daily routine, they can have
memories of a trip implanted into their memory.
Doug Quaid is having visions of a mission
on Mars, and goes to Rekall to live out the
Secret Agent fantasy.
Quaid opts to “go” to Mars, and when hearing
the pitch, he’s told that he will “save
the girl, kill the bad guys, and save the
entire planet!”
Once Quaid receives the memory and the action
kicks into high gear, that’s exactly what
happens.
Quaid falls for a woman and saves the oppressed
people of Mars by wiping out all the villains.
Spider-Man 3
After learning Peter Parker’s secret in
Spider-Man 2, Harry Osborn swears to avenge
his father and take down his former friend.
That is, until he takes a nasty hit to the
head and suffers amnesia.
When Peter and Mary Jane visit Harry at the
hospital, they reconnect like it’s old times,
and the nurse notes that the trio has a strong
bond.
Harry mentions that he cares about his friends
so much, he’d die for them.
Turns out, he was actually predicting his
fate.
In the third act as Spider-Man fights off
Venom and the Sandman, Harry pays the ultimate
price.
Psycho
Norman Bates is far from a normal person,
and his relationship with his mother is interesting
to say the least.
When Marion Crane checks into the Bates Motel,
she overhears Norman having an argument with
his mother, who is acting emotionally abusive
towards her son.
Marion suggests that she’s toxic, but Norman
defends Mom, saying that she’s “as harmless
as one of those stuffed birds.”
Turns out, Mom has a little more in common
with those birds than she would like.
It’s revealed at the end that Norman killed
and stuffed his own mother.
But he wouldn’t hurt a fly, right?
Final Destination
A film built around gory kills should want
to keep the grisly murders a secret, but the
makers of Final Destination had other plans.
In the opening credits, there are images of
objects such as a guillotine, axe, and … They
look like things that just fit in with the
tone of the movie, but they actually represent
the manner in which the main characters die
during the course of the film.
At least audiences didn’t see who got killed
by each weapon, but these are surprises that
would have been better served for a more satisfying
reveal.
Jaws
As the town of Amity Island is under attack
by a rogue shark, it’s up to three unlikely
heroes to find it and kill it.
For their hunt, Brody, Quint, and Hooper bring
a variety of tools that could be useful in
their quest.
One item of Hooper’s is a tank of compressed
air, and Brody wonders aloud how that can
help them get the shark.
Quint makes the offhand comment that the big
fish could eat it, which ends up being a little
bit of foreshadowing.
When Brody is the only left to take out the
shark, he gets the upper hand by tossing the
tank in the shark’s mouth and shooting it.
Star Trek Into Darkness
We mentioned this one is our other video “10
Amazing Clues You Missed In Movies” but
we just couldn’t leave it out!
When The Vengeance ship made its appearance
in the film, audiences shouldn’t have been
surprised since much earlier in a scene where
Kirk and Spock meet Admiral Marcus, his office
has a collection of every ship from the Star
Trek Universe.
The camera dollies
Through all of them and ends on… you guessed
it… the brand new Vengeance in the foreground!
Were they even trying to hide it?
So what do you think of our list?
Which movie spoilers do you notice early in
the film?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!